[Music]
what
so Kevin we just played some StarLink
battle for Atlas no we did what do you
think of it Tony I had a good time
playing it StarLink is of course the
toys to life game from Ubisoft it's part
space exploration part planet
exploration part shooter and probably
the biggest hook is that if you're
playing the switch version you get to
play the whole thing with the starfox
characters but I came away with with a
pretty positive response I think ok well
I'm in the same boat I hadn't had any
any chances to go hands-on with a game
before this and I thought it was all
pretty neat and the immediate thing that
stands out to me is that all that ship
customization is instantaneous mm-hmm
you pull off a wing you pull off a gun
and you want to swap it in it is
immediate you want to even switch pilots
or the entire ship you're using it's
immediate and you can actually toggle
that you can set it so that it just
swaps as you're playing the game or by
default it pauses while you switch the
parts so you're not like you know
suddenly without a weapon in the middle
of a firefight yeah but you can you
can't have that option if you want to
just literally not even pause the game
and just hot-swap I don't think I would
ever be able to do that because it's a
pretty fast pace when you get into a
firefight with stuff and if you actually
need to change out a weapon so I enjoyed
having it automatically pause so I can
do that and I'm surprised it was
actually it was probably my favorite
aspect of the game you mention how
fast-paced the combat and stuff gets it
is very fast-paced but at least when you
first meet a new enemy type at least
then the demo build we played that you
get a message on screen that
specifically tells you hey this enemy is
weak to this sort of weapon and so you
can actually just immediately there
while that tutorial screen is up I'll
swap your weapons right there so you
know you're going into the battle with
the best equipment possible yeah all
right I think I'm coming up on the -
wish me luck so that's where imps come
from this structure must be controlling
them somehow
it's important to note that you don't
need to use the weapons I suggest in
order to take on those enemies but if
you do happen to have them you know
handy then it'll definitely give you the
advantage in that battle yeah it's also
important to note that even using the
the ship parts on your controller is
totally optional - yeah like I said it
has that toys to life influence of you
actually have like the ship there in
front of you but you don't have to use
that if you don't want to and I think
some people may choose not to I don't
know if this was the case for you but I
know for me I kind of felt like the way
the ship because it literally clips onto
your controller it made a few button
presses a little weird I was using the
Xbox one controller and like especially
trying it to click the I think it's the
tiles button the one on the left side
pressing that around the ship was
actually a little awkward and I know you
play on a Nintendo switch so was that
equally it was yeah you can definitely
tell it's geared toward younger gamers
but having the ship actually resting on
the controller doesn't make pressing
buttons a little bit more cumbersome
than it would be yeah and fortunately
that is totally optional so we talked
about comment and comment is a lot of
fun it feels really fast it flows really
nicely but the game is more than just
combat because especially in that first
chapter we crash-landed on to a planet I
think you said no man's sky kind of felt
like a comparison there uh-huh it
definitely brought a lot of comparisons
to know my Scott when I was playing it
because it's very exploratory because I
was expecting to be more mission based
and there are missions but those are
kind of pretty optional I think they
seem to like pop up while you're playing
and you can choose like oh I would like
to take on this mission and they follow
it down that way or you can completely
ignore and go somewhere completely
different on the planet missions in the
sense of like of like waypoints popping
up and then you can just kind of yeah
because there was like the the story
mission of okay we need to get off of
this planet so let's find a fuel cell or
whatever whatever the material was they
needed to escape oh good you're back
wait you're not Fickett where's my
assistant when you need him as you're
going around the planet like we said you
will you will find more waypoints your
map will fill out they'll be like enemy
bases and optional objectives and sort
of like control towers but it's not like
other Ubisoft games where you've got to
find the tower
map the planet or anything like that the
map does grow as you explore the planet
and it seems you could go to any planet
you want basically from the outside well
he's from our experience with the demo
because I was taken on one mission and I
had flown in a completely different
direction from the planet I was supposed
to be on and ended up on a completely
different planet I know for me I just
you know landed it and did the the story
mission but I think it is worth just
saying in general it you focus more on
the starfox type missions I went more
for the campaign stuff starfox uh didn't
feel any really any different from the
main game as far as what you have to do
I think it's just a way to tie in wolf
and all the other starfox characters
although Ubisoft says if you want you
could play through the entire game as
Fox whole starfox crew is integrated in
all the cutscenes and stuff in the
switch version if you wanted to use that
and I think Fox adds a lot of appeal to
the game
but so it doesn't play any different
with photos just more in the more the
aesthetics yeah in the voice-acting
obviously I do agree that that's a good
hook
especially since Ubisoft already kind of
proved that they can do some cool things
with Nintendo after Mario Rabbids now we
have this makes me excited for further
Ubisoft Nintendo partnerships honestly
it would be interesting to see Ubisoft
try to take on a traditional starfox
game yeah since they've integrated
starfox so well too startling so
customization is quick and easy and it
feels good but having the physical ship
there is completely optional which is
nice because as we were both saying it
it kind of feels a little claustrophobic
on the controller and the starfox thing
is also a nice addition despite it not
changing any gameplay it adds a lot as
far as personality yeah I'm definitely
gravitate towards a switch version just
because of starfox is inclusion well all
versions of the game are dropping on
October 16th wherever you're picking it
up and you can stay tuned to games for
more coverage of StarLink and battle for
Atlas m5 is toast ah wonderful know hive
no imps just the way I like it I have
some electrum waiting here for you as
promised our ship actually takes Nova